un ataque brutal
el escritor indio salman rushdie fue
apuñalado en el cuello y el abdomen fue
en nueva york durante una conferencia
sobre escritores y artistas en el exilio
pilar pin tagro estuvo en el lugar del
suceso
pensábamos que le estaba acomodando el
micrófono o algo así porque fue muy
rápido y empezó entró por la mano
izquierda sin forma derecha y empezó a
apuñalarme varias veces la primera fue
la el cáncer que al cuello y la sangre
empezó a salir y se manos y en un
momento se paró y corrió para olvidarlo
tras el ataque rasheed y fue atendido en
el lugar hasta que pudo ser trasladado
también fue detenido el atacante
identificado como hadi matar de 24 años
y de facebook nueva jersey la policía
trata de esclarecer los motivos
no tengo ni idea en este momento como
dije es muy temprano no tenemos ningún
indicio de ningún motivo en este momento
un helicóptero transportó a raya a un
hospital pese a la rápida reacción
público y analistas denuncian fallas en
la prevención de seguridad lo que debe
haberse hecho de manera óptima para algo
como esto es tener a gente sin
eleccionario de izquierda a derecha para
evitar la brecha en el escenario
así era un icono mundial por su lucha
contra el integrismo religioso así
reaccionó el presidente de francia de
manuel macrón en twitter durante 33 años
salman rushdie ha encarnado la libertad
y la lucha contra el oscurantismo su
lucha es la nuestra universal desde 1988
pesaba en su contra una fatua desde irán
en un llamado para asesinarle y con una
recompensa de unos 3 millones de dólares